[MUSIC PLAYING]
These ants are working in
tandem to form a bridge.
Even though there's no
leader giving orders,
they all seem to
know what to do.
Similarly, thousands
of starlings
fly in unison, creating
complex formations in the sky.
Magnetic properties
arise from the alignment
of billions of electrons.
Intricate frost patterns
crystallize on window panes.
Hurricanes form above
churning oceans,
and once clear highways suddenly
get jammed with traffic.
These different
systems all share
something in common, some sort
of macro property or behavior
arises spontaneously from
many interacting micro parts.
It's a classic case of
the whole being greater
than the sum of its parts.
The behavior of
each of those parts
doesn't predict how they
behave collectively.
Some of our greatest
unsolved mysteries,
like how life first began,
and how our brains give
rise to consciousness could be
explained by this phenomenon,
known as emergence.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
How does complexity emerge
from a simple starting point,
and how do we even study that?
Let's look at the formation
of a crystal lattice.
Think of molecules
in a container.
At high temperatures, they'll
bounce around independently
in a fluid or gaseous state.
Poke them, and nothing
happens to the system,
but lower the temperature
and they form a solid.
They crystallize,
arranging themselves
in a regular lattice.
A balancing act
between opposing forces
maintains the distance
between molecules.
Now, poke them.
They'll try to
restore the balance.
The key is, the forces acting
on the molecules don't change.
The drop in temperature added
a new condition to the system.
The same rules created
a different effect.
And that's how the
properties of the crystal
lattice, like its rigidity, its
elasticity, and its long range
order emerge.
An abrupt change in the
behavior of a physical system
is something we typically
think of as a phase transition.
In fact, that's how
scientists often
think about emergence
in more complex systems.
Let's return to the
bridge building ants.
Like the molecules
in the lattice,
the ants as individuals obey
the same behavioral rules,
no matter what they're doing.
They aren't trying
to build structures.
But when the ground drops
away in front of the swarm,
old rules about how close
to stay to their neighbors
leads to the emergence of large
scale coordinated behavior.
Without that information
about their neighbors,
the bridge would
break apart, just
like how higher
temperatures cause
molecules to break from a solid
lattice into a liquid state.
Emergence means that we can
find hierarchies of new laws
and structures that arise out of
complexity at different scales.
Scientists are seeking to apply
the framework of emergence
to other areas of research,
like how individual cells follow
cues to move or transform
when organs are developing.
Or how groups of
neurons fire together,
to help you make decisions.
Some researchers are
even hoping to engineer
such systems of their own, to
build robotic systems made up
of small dumb parts that
end up swarming together
to perform useful tasks.
Perhaps this work can
help us understand
even deeper questions
about the emergent nature
of intelligence,
consciousness, and life itself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]